hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to pogo stuck
i realized that i was at fault in the
last few episodes because i
was being far too negative it kept me up
at night
made me feel remorseful about my
negative attitude towards this game so
i realized that if i go into this in a
positive attitude and i don't let
anything get to me
then i should be able to conquer this
mountain even if i do have a cheat i'm
still going to keep that i'm not going
to give that up because i need a little
bit of joy in my heart to be able to
carry on
if i'm not giving up the boost
to sit i'm not giving up the
i'm not going to give up the boost to
save my life i've become completely
reliant on it
and there's literally no way that i
would ever be able to do it without it
there's literally no way i would ever i
don't even know how you'd make the bee
jump without it
actually you know it's entirely possible
it it must be possible i have full faith
that these developers know exactly what
they're doing with this game
and furthermore they've play tested it
certainly enough that they have
my full confidence in how to properly
play this game oh my god how do
oh my god i'm here i'm here i'm there
i'm gone ah i mean back here
no why would i do that why did i try oh
my oh it's fine you know
setbacks it's because i was relying on a
a technique that wasn't
the intended technique and therefore
should should i be even be surprised
that i didn't get it correctly
no of course not oh maybe i could just
oh
ah that's close maybe
maybe boom oh
interesting look it's a technique it's
not
it's a shortcut it's a shortcut i'm
trying to do this as
much legit as i can i'm not i know it's
thank you for saving me big nog the big
nog in my head big saved me big time i
gotta admit this is cute
it's very cute oh hey buddy
teeth hi teeth can i go this way
and one more bounce oh my god please ah
oh my god oh my god no
no teeth damn it oh i'm fine
yes oh my god where am i
frick up
oh why did i oh i shouldn't have
boosted god it's my over reliance on
this
cheaty mechanic it really is gonna be
the death of me
because this probably should be able to
be done
yeah it should yeah exactly oh
crap
i'm sorry what i i will readily admit
that
like i know it's entirely possible
without the double jump
but my goodness it it seems like if this
game was
designed to have to have it like if you
if you if you
started off with double jump and they
took it away like that would be hell
it would feel so unfair yeah
yes okay no god i said okay if i say
okay that means
it's okay and you should just let me
carry on i'm
fine this should be able to be done
without oh
okay nope oh
no there you go it should be able to be
done without any boost
i think that's what's throwing me off in
that because i keep trying to use boost
but in reality i don't ah shoot
oh there i go but in reality it
shouldn't be necessary right
okay great thank you for that
like i know it's not oh wow
oh stop oh my goodness now like i know
it's possible without so
i i don't think i should use it because
i think it's messing me up
if i actually just did it correctly then
theoretically i should be able to
conquer that section
without too much trouble right okay
just do it without it without it nope
not doing it without there there oh god
i did the thing again i did the the same
thing i did before
which is just try to boost over that
which is not what i need to do
i'm not even 100 uh where am i it's like
lottery
it's like a bounce lottery i always do
it once
perfectly because i'm cautious and then
every subsequent attempt
i throw caution to the wind and i'm like
i got this i'm a pro
what just happened i have no idea what
just happened that was strange
i slid right past the bee's buttocks
no why why why
no why stop
oh come on
oh come on damn it
oh my god oh my god
can you just get the timing right can
you please
oh my god it's perfect to the b it's so
perfect to the b oh my god
this is worse than if i just did it
normally
uh and you miss it by oh frick off
this is hell i'm in hell i'm in hell i'm
in hell
i'm in hell okay
okay okay where am i going where am i
going where am i going where am i going
where am i going i'm gonna hit this beat
look i don't know what i'm trying to do
i just feel like this is better than
going through the stupid b
gap to try to do the b beach oh
i just had to say the words b-gap
the computer heard me and it was like oh
you you
you need to be over by the b-gap come on
oh my god i have a cheat code
i know through the gap
ah and there's a bee there of course
there yes perfect exactly what i always
wanted
where am i going i don't know i don't
know what i'm doing
oh please let there be a bee god damn it
of course there wasn't of course there
wasn't
like i can always hit the bees when i
don't want to hit the bees
and then when i do want to hit the bees
they'll never be there it's the law
of bee i really don't know what i'm
trying to accomplish here
but trust me when i say when i do
finally accomplish
my dreams oh yes through the gap of me
thank you yes okay here we go and double
jump
and up to the wall i'm not facing the
right direction for that
and oh yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes
[Music]
be
god i'm oh my god
i was right there if the stupid
computer update didn't didn't
screw me over last night i would have
had that
because i would have been at the right
angle i was taking it nice and slow i
had done it the correct way
like everything was lined up to be
perfect and yet
i got screwed because that's how this
game does
that's just what this game does it's
cruising no
positive it is not it's a computer
program
it cannot feel it has no desires
to screw me it would not have that
because that does not make sense
if they did oh my god if they did
oh my god and every time i get the
timing when i'm like oh yeah now is when
it would be free i
i balls it up and i oh god
just touch the thing right
you've done it before there now god
oh my god
i don't know what i'm doing how did i
make this before
like this yes oh my god this is it is it
is it
is it is it boom
yes
[Music]
i'm now less than halfway to the top
okay
so like before just take everything nice
and slow
[ __ ] dude [ __ ]
take everything nice and slow
where am i going what am i looking for
no
where am i going exactly
what was the lag
[Music]
oh my god oh my god
oh my god what was the lag
what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] oh my god
oh my god the game is very intentionally
messing with me
there's no denial of that now
i don't know i don't know i don't know
what i'm doing anymore i
i've completely lost it and i really
just don't know what i'm doing what i'm
going for
what what am i going for what uh what am
i going for
what am i trying to do i've forgotten my
brain
literally shut down and i no longer know
exactly what i was doing
what is my goal in life what is my
purpose
oh my god
no no damn it
stop where am i going
okay here we go no there was supposed to
be a bee
okay come on please
maybe that's a good technique just if i
can climb the wall
yeah just i don't know how i'll never be
able to replicate what i did
it was pretty impressive whatever it was
but it wasn't intentional i
guarantee you that
damn it damn it damn it damn it damn it
damn it damn it damn it damn
yes yes yes
yes easy done done okay
i'm just gonna keep going where am i
going ah to the left i see it
to the left nope oh
[ __ ] oh
oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god there i go
[Music]
windows update is moving to different
monitors on my computer
to try to remind me the i didn't pause
that's windows update again
why [ __ ] off when i say tomorrow
i mean [ __ ] tomorrow
oh my god i [ __ ] bullseye okay yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] me
[ __ ] [ __ ] me [ __ ] me i
the thing is like i know when it's gonna
send me through the gap i
i am very well aware of when i'm gonna
go through the gap i'm
fully aware way before it actually
happens
and [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
i am so mad no i'm so happy
i'm so happy i get another chance to
play through this
level of the game again because i love
this game so much because this game is
so fun
so of course i would be spending so much
time on it because if i wasn't
enjoying myself it would make no sense
as to why i was playing it so much
you know i i just want to see these
sections over and over again because
they're fun
because they're so cool and well
designed and just just a joy to be
[Music]
around
no those two oh frick no
frick oh my god oh [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh please be please
be there oh man i
am having so much fun
damn it oh that okay it doesn't matter
anyway cause i'm going away and i'm
gonna hit a b
i knew it
you know what what if this [ __ ] here
i just said
[ __ ] it too yep you know what i'm saying
a big old oh do not do that to me
do not do that to me yes
yes exactly and this is exactly what
i've always wanted
where am i going where am i going
oh no no not like this is this is this
where i need to be
oh my god it is oh my god it is oh my
god here we go
here we go no no no no oh my god
oh my god oh why are you sleeping
where why are you while y'all doing oh
my goodness
interesting interesting interesting
interesting
fascinating
fascinating fascinating very fascinating
interesting okay interesting interesting
interesting interesting interesting
so avoid that and avoid that
so how wait i'm a little confused
ah shoot okay fascinating
interesting new developments
predicaments interesting new
things to consider so if you're just
bouncing on them you're fine
yeah if you're just bouncing on them
you're fine so i think the trick is to
just
bounce on them and have your boost ready
yes okay okay
just have your bounce ready
yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes wait what hmm what's this
uh okay
i've made it farther i'm proud of myself
i'm proud of what i've done that'll be
it for today i
am very excited to see what new
challenges i'm going to face
in the next portion of the game i love
you i hope you have a good day
take care bye bye
subscribe okay bye
[Music]
you